hey here's a story that this is not like
a big news story but people flagged it
for me and it's just kind of you know
anytime there's a win in the battle of
the churning of ideas that's the new hot
phrase to churn ideas like butter I do
like to mention it Eric Weinstein is a
member of the intellectual dark web nice
guy I've spoken to him a few times he
was interviewed by a guy named David
Fuller who has a YouTube channel called
rebel wisdom I've been interviewed by
David fuller previously they had a
conversation a couple days ago and David
fuller asked Erik Weinstein an
interesting question are there any
critiques that you think have been
valuable or useful now I can't actually
tell whether the question is are there
critiques of the intellectual dark web
that have been useful or are there
critiques of the left by people on the
left that have been useful I'm not
actually sure which the question is
asking but what was interesting was that
Eric Weinstein said a lot of people are
doing schoolyard type stuff but when
David Pakman is at his best which
clearly is not all the time that's okay
when I'm at my best I've done some good
critiques and again I don't know if it's
of the IDW or of the left from the left
let's take a look are there any
critiques that you think would have been
valuable open useful very few there have
been a few but very few well
it's really been pretty slim pickins
David Pakman at his best I think has
been a pretty astute and fair observer
on the harder I didn't want to call it
harder left means he stormed sort of
weirdly between the woke in the IDW you
know then there are people who are very
smart like for example I think of Sam
cedar is being very informed on policy
terms like he's actually following a
particular bill or you know probably
knows the names of staffers on the hill
that kind of granular detail the problem
with him is that he's got a strong
trolling game and kind of a comedic
ridicule game that is a turn-off to I
mean it's okay as a wit but it's not
okay as a main course and so I think
that you could pick through the Sam
cedar stuff and find reasonable stuff
but I wouldn't recommend it because of
the reliance on ridicule so there is
Eric Weinstein saying I think if I
understand it correctly that when I'm at
my best which is not all the time of
course I've done some okay critiques
either of the intellectual dark web or
maybe he means critiques of the left
from the left I believe that this is a
compliment now if you've not been
following the intellectual dark web or
woke nice he says I'm between the IDW
and the woke left these are two
different movements that have surfaced
at least starting online the
intellectual dark web is a sort of group
of commentators who could be on the left
or on the right but their big thing is
they're opposed to identity politics
they're opposed to political correctness
and sacred cows language policing
restrictions on speech taboos etc it
includes people like Eric Weinstein
himself as well as his brother Brett it
includes Sam Harris and Michael Shermer
and then I don't know who else is within
it or or outside of it I'm not really
sure the woke movement or woke Ness
refers generally to the left-wing
movement that includes a
particular type of cultural awareness
around race and feminism and LGBT
activism and socially liberal causes
racial justice is a big thing and it's
sometimes used as a pejorative and
sometimes it's not sometimes it's have
you become woke as a positive thing I
think in this context Eric is using woke
nests as a pejorative and IDW as good
and maybe is placing me between the two
so as soon as this happened there were
people online furious that if Eric
Weinstein is saying something good about
david pakman david pakman must be really
bad other people saw this and said hey
that's actually pretty interesting what
I'm hearing I'm leaving it at this it
sounds to me like Eric is just saying
I'm at least honest and genuine in my
critiques I know that Eric has not
agreed with every one of my critiques of
the IDW we've spoken about it before and
that's fine but for me this is less
about oh where do I agree or disagree
with the woke left or with the IDW for
me it's more about my commitment to you
as a viewer or listener has always been
I'm not going to just say stuff for
clicks when it's not really what I
believe if what I really believe
generates interest and builds an
audience that's great if it doesn't and
you all know there have been cases where
I've just given you my opinion and lost
subscribers well then that's too bad but
my priority is I'll tell you things as I
see them and hopefully me being genuine
and honest is what Eric is pointing to
here I've spoken to Eric about having
him on the program still an open
invitation to do it anytime he's ready